is the world's leading venue for
collaborative research in theoretical
computer science and it was established
in 2012 by by Grant from Simons
Foundation who continues to support us
and uh broadly the goal of the
institute's semester programs clusters
workshops other Outreach activities is
to explore the use of algorithmic
thinking in computer science and
adjacent fields and to U have focused
efforts to understand the laws of
computation
itself um so a few logist SS before we
start with the workshop uh so food is
provided outside in the breaks food and
coffee is provided lunch is not provided
and you're welcome to go check out the
restaurants nearby for lunch uh one
useful thing you can do uh there are
some lockers on that side of the
building where you can leave your stuff
when you go out to lunch uh and we do
ask that you don't bring food back here
in uh to keep the auditorium
clean so that's all about food the other
thing is all the talks are recorded uh
and by our videographer Omid far who's
over there so if if anyone has has any
problems then he'll he'll help you uh
during the talk uh or during the
workshop um finally yeah we do invite
you to if you're going to Tweet about
this we invite you to do so but do tag
us on Twitter Simons Institute and we
will retweet
you uh and finally I want to give a big
thanks to Ashley Hassen who did all of
the logistics for this Workshop
including re reimbursements
accommodation
ET so uh so thank you and here's gelani
who will uh say some more
things morning everyone uh maybe just
before we start with the first talk by
by Mt um let me just say a couple things
about the schedule so we do have an open
problem session tomorrow that's four to
5m you're not required to tell us your
open problems ahead of time but if you
want to uh you know there's always like
this awkward thing I've sometimes seen
at the beginning where we say okay now
the open problem session and then
there's a pause at the beginning where
we have to push people to start so if
you want to help me get help us get
started off immediately just email me
and say I want to present an open
problem and if you want to say your
problem in the email you can I'll just
write down my email
[Applause]
here okay um so that's for the open
problem session tomorrow 4: to 5m we
will also have lightning talks tomorrow
morning um and that's just the way for
people to introduce themselves and what
they work on to the rest of you if you
want to give a lightning talk three
minutes max okay or shorter also just
send an email and probably also send me
a PDF of your slides so slow
transition um other than that there are
some discussion slots that are built
into the schedule at the end of some
days those are more just like breaks
where we encourage you to stick around
and talk to each other it's nothing
formal okay so with that being said um
oh and there was a question about ventil
and air conditioning okay so we don't
have air conditioning in this building
unfortunately I asked most buildings uh
don't in East Bay but the best we have
our fans uh and we put the fans on Max
but you know we'll see how well that
works out okay so oh last thing very
last thing I promise uh during q&as
please ask your questions into a mic we
have two mics we'll pass mics around and
we also ask the speaker answer questions
into the mic because this is being
recorded and put on YouTube so for the
benefit of those who are not in the room
we would like everything to be recorded
it' also be helpful for speakers if you
could repeat questions that are asked to
you okay thank you uh so let's
[Applause]
begin okay first of all I'd like to
thank the organizers for the kind
invitation and thank you all of you for
being here so I'll be talking about
randomizing embeddings and neural
networks so I'll start with some current
challenges we're facing with deep neural
networks then I'll introduce you what
the randomize embeddings is it's a
mathematical construction that we use in
sketching methods to make higher
dimensional data lower dimensional then
I'll introduce you a model for neural
networks based on conx optimization so
this part will be new and we will use
randomizing medings in these convex pro
programs programs for solving neural
network problems and finally I will show
you a ifying framework based on Clifford
algebra if you have if you have enough
time so we have witnessed the impact of
deep neural networks they are working
extremely efficiently in computer vision
robotics uh more recently in language
models I'm sure you heard of uh chat GPT
I asked chat GPT uh what does a sketch
mean in the context of randomized
algorithms and it gives you a very good
answer in the context of randomized
algorithm the sketch is a compressed
representation of data um the goal is to
capture the essential features of a data
set and the purpose of this is to allow
algorithms work on massive data sets uh
and we usually have randomized
constructions based on random matrices
or some hashing
function uh actually today now you can
also ask chat GP to generate an image a
description an illustration this is the
dolly model it comes up with this it's a
funnel metaphor so Mass data goes in and
then you have sketch coming out uh this
is done by randomized algorithms the
sketch extracts this essential part of
the data set this is done with an neural
network too it is a diffusion model
these diffusion models they basically
create hallucinations from random noise
they work amazingly well but sometimes
you don't want hallucinations this is
one example in medical imaging neural
networks similar uh to the ones in the
diffusion model are used to the noise
and magnetic resonance imaging um uh
signal and it turns out actually in the
Reconstruction it hallucinates a false
vessel this is not really there it is
imagined by the neural network so this
is of course not acceptable for a
medical imaging so the point I'm trying
to make is deep learning is really
working great but they are complex
blackbox systems it is based on massive
amounts of
data uh these models are also extremely
large models like gpt3 has billions of
parameters gp4 we don't know it's not
announced um and training is a big
challenge neural networks are so large
the data they're trained on is also
extremely large um and there's one
fundamental challenge in training neural
networks from my perspective the first
problem is non-convexity many machine
learning models like lease course
logistic regression these are based on
convex optimization this is actually
important because whenever you define a
loss function there's typically a unique
minimizer the model is determined by
that uh function in the neural network
case it's not the it's not the case
anymore because it is non-convex you run
some algorithm it does have some
parameters in it like initialization
step sizes
optimizers um it will find you something
and this becomes very very black uh bux
which is hard to understand and also
hard to Trin um from the theory
perspective even training a two- layer
neural network is NP hard unless p is
equal to
NP so there are lots of open questions
around this how do we make training R
networks more efficient how do we deal
with high dimensional data High
dimensional models and also underlying
uh core problems are how do we develop a
foundational Theory and how do we
interpret these models so what I will
try to show you today is somewhat
surprisingly randomized embeddings they
play a very essential role in in all
three training them better faster more
efficient uh also developing some
foundational Theory it will be based on
randomizing Tings and also interpreting
these models what do they really do this
will also be in the language of randomiz
Tings and sketching uh the the math
tools we use in sketching surprisingly
they pop up they uh are things we
encounter in in neural networks so here
is the high level overview so first I
will introduce you a convex optimization
model
these are reformulations of neural
network problems which are actually
non-convex but turns out that there's an
embedding which takes them and maps to a
convex
space um then it will be a high
dimensional convex program so we are
trading off some kind of hardness which
is non-convexity with some other kind of
hardness convexity but high
dimensionality and this will be dealt
with randomized
embeddings and there will be some Global
optimality approximation guarantees
based on randomized sampling and there
are interesting connections to zonotopes
and Clifford
algebra okay so I'll introduce you what
randomiz embeddings are this is a
mathematical construction so basically
you have K points living in N dimensions
and there's a function f which is
mapping these n dimensional points to M
dimensions and M is much less than
n uh what we want from this edting is
that the distances are preserved after
the embedding approximately we should
have same similar distances and the
classical embedding that we know in this
field is the Johnson Linden Ross
embedding uh it's very simple it is a
linear map so what you do is you
generate a Matrix S which is M by n it's
a wide Matrix it reduces Dimensions n to
M and what it does is actually with high
probability you see that the distances
here are preserved approximately if you
have order log K dimensions in this
embedding and K is the number of points
surprisingly this number which is the
critical Dimension you can embed to
doesn't even depend on the original
ambient Dimension n it only depends on
how many points you have and this is
actually surprising result did have lots
of implications in abstract math
functional analysis yes but also in the
practice of algorithms we use these type
of constructions in algorithms um and
this is what led to the work in
sketching um it is possible to
generalize this uh to any Norm you can
embed from a p Norm to a q Norm which
means you look at the Q Norm of s times
a vector Z and then you want to preserve
P Norms right p and Q can be basically
anything um and here the Set uh of
vectors it doesn't have to be a discrete
set finite set it can actually be a
continuous uh non-discrete set it can be
a Subspace for
instance um here is one example a
Subspace embedding which is actually
very common in the theory of sketching
so we choose p and Q equal to two we use
ukan norms and we take the set V the
range of a matrix and this Matrix will
be n by D and assume for now that n is
much larger than D and this will
basically correspond to a regression
problem we have lots of samples and the
dimension D is smaller than the number
of samples so we generate a random s
there are many ways to generate this s
you can make it IID plus one minus one
or IID gaussian and there are much
faster ways better ways of doing this
there are sampling based uh matrices s
uh all all other kinds um and it turns
out that a random s will give you this
result any Vector Z in the range of this
Matrix a will have its L2 Norm
approximately preserved when you choose
the edting dimension as low as uh well
greater than rank of a times Epsilon to
minus 2 and here rank of a is actually a
small number because n by D that Matrix
is a tall Matrix typically in regression
problems right rank is at most D
possibly smaller and we are reducing
from Dimension n to the rank of a which
is at most
D so let me show you how this result is
used in sketching so let's say we have
this least course regression problem
which is basically about taking a vector
Y and then projecting it onto the range
of a and you might have guessed if you
preserve the range space information
right you will actually preserve
optimality approximately in this problem
if you have n rows and D columns and N
is greater or equal to d uh solving this
problem in the original space without
any randomization is um sometimes
challenging if n andd are large with
direct methods you need complexity and d
squ uh and if you have iterative methods
like conjugate gradient they will give
you an approximation in order ND times
uh some condition number dependent
quantity and with sketching actually
this can be made much faster so uh what
is the process let's say we call the
objective F of ax it's a function of a *
X and then we call the optimal value opt
this is the original problem and then a
a is a tall Matrix n by D containing
measurements so you multiply this Matrix
on the left by S which is this sketch
this random uh Matrix and then you get
this tiny stimes a matrix which is M byd
right and then the idea is very simple
you solve the approximation which has
stimes a and S times y right and since
we know this s does not uh perturb
distances in the range of a too much we
expect actually X hat the minimizer of
this to be an approximation to this
problem so that's that's basically the
idea um you can make S uh composed of
IID gaussian entries but there are
actually much better ways uh you can
form this product s times a faster based
on constructions like the foret
transform this is inspired by working
compress sensing you take a foret
transform and randomly sample the rows
that's one way it will take order andd
time ignoring logarithmic terms uh which
is actually good it is actually as fast
as reading data in a it cannot actually
be faster than this and if the Matrix a
is sparse which is actually usually the
case in machine learning uh there are
other constructions based on sparse
matrices and you can bring the cost down
of forming stimes a to order n andz of a
where n andz is the number of non-zeros
in a and this is pretty good actually
the fastest algorithms we know to
approximate the solution to a constant
Factor factor and a one plus Epsilon
factor is based on these sparse
embeddings so here is one result uh for
approximation of the cost uh the
earliest such result is due to SAR loss
from 2006 and then over the years this
result was improved and I worked
personally in this area quite a lot this
is actually from our latest paper um so
if you choose the embedding Dimension as
1 plus rank times 1 plus 1/ Epsilon
which is slightly larger than the rank
and the dependence on the rank of a is
1/ Epsilon then you will have a one plus
Epsilon relatively optimal
solution and it turns out that this is
the best Bond you can get this cannot be
improved there's also a matching lower
bound this will happen with high
probability so this is the case these
are exact numbers with the gaussian uh
sketch IID gaussian sketch for others
there are other formulas like this there
are other expressions and then there are
constant factors the critical quantity
is actually the rank of a divided by
Epsilon
controlling the error and here's one
practical application of this let's say
you have a real data set this is the
airline data set which contains flight
arrival uh time of flight destination
these kind of uh information it's a real
data set 120 million rows and 28 columns
okay so it data for 120 million flights
if you choose the embedding Dimension to
500 you solve a really really tiny
problem which is 500 by 28 and then you
will get according to these results 1.6
uh 1.06 approximation and because
there's one over Epsilon dependence if
you add one more zero here to the
embedding Dimension you will have
another zero here and turns out that
this is the optimal scaling this cannot
be
improved question I think here you seem
to be describing an experiment
experimentally does the approximation
really match the 1 one or is it better
yeah the question is in practice does
this match exactly Yes actually it does
match exactly because there is a result
which shows that the approximation ratio
is really concentrated around this value
so you have an upper Bond and lower Bond
and the concentration is exponential
this is the case with gaussian Sketch
though
dat oh okay very good question does this
depend on the data set actually the
result is uh says no it doesn't depend
on the particular data set because
whenever you have a gaussian random
Matrix you multiply your data with it it
actually makes everything gaussian so it
doesn't really uh depend on the
particular data set there's some sort of
universality does that make sense this
is not proved for other sketches like
sparse and for year Bay but for gaussian
we know this is the case it is actually
Universal uh very good question thank
you um
okay so I will introduce you another
kind of a sketch this is what I call
quantized embeddings okay this is
actually a much more aggressive form of
uh sketching let's say you have a set of
points and they are taken on the surface
of the unit Sphere for some reason that
will be clear um and then we have a
random Matrix M byn reducing Dimension
exactly same as before but we take the
sign of s * Z for a vector Z so our
embedding is actually to the Heming Cube
we actually get a plus one minus one bit
string okay so this is much more
aggressive you reduce dimensions and
then map it to plus one minus ones so I
call this quantized eddings because you
can quantize them uh this is known uh as
other things uh for instance locality
sensitive hashing is another way another
name for this so what really happens is
the following in the space of Z's here
it's Z1 Z2 uh we have these planes S1
transpose Z equals z the withd normal S1
and then S2 transpose Z equals z
depending on actually which region you
fall fall into right in terms of Z you
get a different pattern right it will be
one one if you have uh positive inner
products if one is negative you will
have minus one right so it divides the
space into uh regions and inside each
region there is a bit pattern right the
vector is mapped to um so these are
called hyperplane Arrangements which is
basically AET of planes and the regions
the sets created in between them right
we have
Chambers um and I call these are
generated by the roves of s the normals
of these planes are the roves of s and
it turns out that there is a similar
notion as in JL embedding to preserve uh
distances in this case it's actually the
hemming
distance uh is preserved relative to
this inverse cosine distance which is
the geodesic distance on the sphere and
this holds with high probability if you
have the sketch Dimension set to
logarithmic in the number of points so
in in sketching and randomized
algorithms this is known as locality
sensitive hashing it's exactly the same
construction right you have a long
Vector you map it to a bit string and
then the bit string is actually
sensitive to similarity in the original
space right and this has lots of uses
another use in is is in compress sensing
right so you have a big high dimensional
signal and it's mapped to just uh
compress data from that you might be
able to reconstruct and more
recently uh we actually appli these in
compressing deep neural networks like
language models uh for instance the
Llama model it turns out that these are
also quite useful in compressing
language models like chat
GPT and there are lots of other problems
where randomized embeddings are are
useful you can have have a streaming
setting for instance in the Le squ
problem the data might be getting
updated because maybe you're reading it
from a big disc or it's a temporal
problem you get new measurements at
every time step right if the data is
updated by some delta T the sketch can
be updated by just updating s times
delta T and if you're using a sparse
sketch and if the updates Delta are also
sparse this becomes very efficient and
you always maintain approximate
optimality well you might be wondering
what happens if the problem you have is
not a tall lead sour but a wide lead s
some high dimensional problem it turns
out that all of those are actually very
similar to the one I showed because in
Conex optimization there is this notion
of condex Duality which takes a problem
and turns into a transposed form you
will have a Le squares problem with the
Matrix a transpose right right so if the
Matrix a is wide you can take the duel
and then multiplying by S transpose on
on the left does exactly the same so all
of these things actually extend to the
case where you have a wide data matrices
by taking
transposes there were also lots of
applications in low rank approximations
like um speeding up singular value
decomposition or tensor
decompositions uh instead of solving the
list cross problem in one shot you can
also construct a precond conditioner
based on these uh sketched matrices this
is also something uh explor in the
literature um previously I worked on
generic convex optimization problems
like logistic regression support Vector
machine semi-definite programs which all
look like this with some large tall
Matrix a it turns out that actually you
can apply sketching to The hhan Matrix
and then the hon Matrix will be smaller
and you can run an approximate Newton
method based on these um sketched Newton
steps and uh finally I know there's lots
of work on constrained and regularized
problems the lead problem can be
regularized or constrained and in those
actually you get better results because
when you have constraints the the
distances you want to preserve they are
in a smaller set they are in a
constrained uh region and because of
that the embedding Dimension actually
can be chosen lower in this case it will
be related to the width of the
constraint set which is called gaussian
width so speaking of regularized
problems the most
important constraint or regularized
version of lead squares that comes to my
mind is this problem L1 regularized lead
scores right this is called lasso this
has lots of applications in statistics
and machine learning what it does is it
will induce sparsity in the solution X
right and very useful if you have lots
of columns of a and only few of those
are actually relevant predictive in uh
forecasting in predicting why right so
elvan Norm is actually uh studied a lot
and it's it's very uh important model
and there's an extension of this model
group L1 regularization so in this case
the vector X is divided into blocks
which we call G1 G2 Etc right and then
the regularization is not the sum of
absolute values it is the sum of L2
Norms of these blocks right and what
this does is it makes the solution
what's called group sparse meaning most
of the blocks XI at the optimum will be
zero right so it's a generalization of
lasso this will reduce to lasso if you
have a group size of one right this is
the generalization of absolute value
basically and this is also used quite a
lot in statistics for instance you might
have predictors which actually come in
groups and then you would like to
identify the relevant groups right a
group actually moves together zero or
non zero right this model is also well
known so this model will be actually
very important in neural networks and I
think this was a surprise for us so now
I'll tell you about neural
networks uh and this convex
reformulations which is actually an
embedding that goes in the other
direction of JL embedding so JL
embeddings map High dimensional data uh
points to low Dimension and it actually
turns out that if you have a non-convex
problem sometimes there's a way to embed
them to high Dimensions so that the
problem will be
convex uh and I know some instances of
this in optimization like in
semi-definite programs this is another
one such case I would say so let's look
at the simplest case of a neural network
problem uh this is the practically
relevant simplest case of a neural
network so we have minimize some loss
this L is some convex loss it can be
scored loss it can be U um cross entropy
loss and then X is our data Matrix n byd
containing samples and we have two
layers to be trained W1 and W2 this
optimization is over them okay and then
Y is a vector of labels and we have this
standard regularization sum of the
squares of every uh trainable parameter
right this is called weight decay in
neural networks and this function f is
the activation function you need this
nonlinearity to make sure your neural
network is actually not reducing to a
simple uh linear model and we pick that
non linearity to be the reu activ
rectified linear unit which is zero and
then X after x equals
z and this was actually quite essential
in the development of deep neural
networks when people switched from other
activations which are smooth to relo
they immediately get better results and
I will show you that there's actually
something very special about these kind
of
activations okay so this is uh from our
recent results first published in uh
2020 um it turns out that there's an
embedding which will take this
non-convex problem map it to a higher
dimensional problem and the higher
dimensional problem will be
convex so it will look
minimizing the same loss over some
variable Matrix Z this Z is d by P okay
so p is some new dimension I'll
introduce and then there's some
regularization R of
Z okay this regularization is actually
very different than the original
original one okay and it turns out that
these two are
identical in the following sense their
objective values are the same the
non-convex one and then convex one and
you can find an optimal solution an
optimal neural
network uh with respect to the first one
using the optimal solution or an optimal
solution to the convex problem okay so
this is actually an embedding result and
why is this possible it's possible
because the dimension p is higher in in
the low dimensional space you have
something very complicated a non-convex
function but there is a mapping to high
Dimensions which will actually entangle
all that um non-convexity and I'll show
you what p is and this is very
interesting things like sketching uh
we'll enter into the
picture Okay so let's see a specific
case we will choose squared loss so that
it will be likely sores and and in fact
later l so um the problem is minimizing
over two layer weights write the square
loss and here I'm writing this over the
neurons I have M neurons in the
non-convex uh neural network model the
convex model is the
following so this is actually just group
lassau it is actually exactly group
lasso which I introduced earlier we have
some Dix UI minus VI minus y the
variables here are uis and VI okay di
are diagonal and fixed matrices
I will show you exactly what they are
these are fixed these are not optimized
they are kind of mimicking what reu does
it will be a diagonal matrix with zeros
or ones on the diagonal and the theorem
says that if you solve this problem you
can construct a neural network using
this formula which is just some scalar
normalization of the solutions UI and VI
basically they are the hidden neurons
optimal hidden
neurons Okay so this problem is just
group lasso basically neural networks
are if you're using ra activation these
are just group lasso models using fixed
features and these features are di times
x matrices okay so next I'll show you
what these are let's look at a very
simple case I will have three samples in
dimension two because I can just plot
them easily I have two two 33 one Z here
plotted on the plane right we will look
at
linear classifiers in this case this one
and we will look at the separation
pattern so in this case all three are on
this side of the plane and because of
that the Matrix D1 is diagonal with all
ones right and this is kind of mimicking
what a Ru neuron is doing to your data
set it will basically pass some s some
samples and then pass some others but
this happens in a structured way there's
this linear classier right which is
separating this one out because of that
you will have a zero here and The Matrix
D1 * X will be the entire training
Matrix D2 * X will be training Matrix
with the third row zeroed out right
which is actually what a single reu
neuron does and then if you look at
other options actually not too many
options are available here you can have
this one too
z01
right so basically in this case the
neural network problem can be written as
a simple convex optimization model we
have these theix matrices which are here
right we have optimization variables U1
V1 U2 V2 Etc right these are constraints
describing which side of the plane the
samples are relative to U1 V1 which are
just linear constraints the interesting
thing here is the regularization we have
some of L2 Norms right and this is the
regularization you have in group lasso
right so operationally what this does is
at the solution you will have very few
nonzero blocks uii right so basically
this is doing the following you have
linear models Associated to subsets of
data right for instance this model has
weights U2 minus V2 it is linear but it
only acts on the first two samples
likewise this is actually acting only on
the third sample right and with this
regularization you're trying to find the
sparest combination of these local
linear models right so this is actually
identical to the reu neural network
which which many people use in uh deep
learning okay so what is the complexity
so you might be wondering if this is
violating any kind of complexity
theoretic uh lower bound so it's
actually
interesting if you have this
model f ofx sum of M neurons times the
second layer uh weights how can we
optimize this Brute Force right so you
have M neurons right for each data
sample it will be on or off you have n
data samples if you do a combinatorial
search Over N comma M right it will be
exponential in n * m right M neurons and
then n samples you need to actually flip
on or off all these neurons and this is
actually what the previous results were
uh these are combinatorial and
complexity is exponential in m and d * m
because they search over every re
pattern but it turns out that this is
not necessary if you solve the convex
problem the dimensions it will be
embedded to is this n / R to power R
where R is the rank of X okay so it's
only exponential in the rank of the data
and this is a big Improvement uh
relative to uh existing work so there
are two cases if n is the number of
samples and D is the
dimension if you have a fixed rank
Matrix this will be polinomial in
everything n and M and it will be a
polinomial time algorithm given that you
can Sol convex programs with polinomial
number of variables it is uh it is
polinomial
time um at least randomize polom po
polinomial time uh the second case is
when the rank is actually full right
it's growing with d in that case it is
exponential in D and it turns out that
this cannot be improved even if you're
training a single neuron we don't know
any polom algorithm in fact you know
that these problems are NP hard so it's
actually not possible to improve this if
the rank is
full um okay why is this interesting
right if it's exponential time and also
why do we have this number n / R to R
right why do we have that so it turns
out that the number of variables in the
condex program
is the number of Chambers you get in a
hyperplan Arrangement so if you look at
x * W sign right which is actually our
quantized
embedding it is basically creating these
Arrangements right you have n planes
whose normals are your data samples
roves of X and if you look at these
regions in between these Arrangements
the number of those chambers is bounded
by n / R to power R it can be actually
smaller but this is an upper bound and R
is the rank of X so the interesting
thing is in convolutional neural
networks this rank is constant
okay and it will become fully polinomial
meaning if polinomial with respect to
all dimensions and you can solve this in
randomized polinomial time so uh for
instance a typical convolution neural
network we'll have layer sizes of 3x3 uh
times 124 indicating 3x3 is the spatial
size of the convolutional filter in this
case it will be uh polinomial
time so what happens if it's not it can
be fully connected right then we have
lots of variables in the convex program
and then the question is how do we solve
these problems faster but luckily we
know many ways if you have a very high
dimensional problem just like a very uh
tall lead scor problem we can actually
apply sketching and randomize sampling
to it right and there's actually a very
natural form of applying this here
because the dis here are diagonal blocks
which is generated by this quantized
embedding right so the idea is we will
randomly sample these variables we
optimize over them and set the rest to
zero okay so we will optimize over a
random set of coordinates basically but
the goal here is to sample
proportionally to some importance
measure because I want the important
variables to be optimized over right
maybe unimportant or less important ones
we can drop right that's the idea so how
do we come up with something like this
it's actually very simple so look at how
these Di generated so it's a diagonal
pattern with this x * UI non negative as
its indicator right is ones and zeros
and this is exactly these quantized
embeddings if I generate lots of uis by
say a thousand uis from any distribution
it can be IID gaussian and I look at X
UI greater or equal zero coordinate wise
it is a pattern right and basically I'm
just applying a locality sensitive hash
right so so the data points are mapped
to the 01 patterns right each one is
assigned to a subset right and then we
minimize this conve
program right basically it is applying
random hashing this quantize random
embedding and then we're training these
UI minus VI right this will be the
idea any questions up to
now okay so how can we analyze something
like this right basically we have
randomly sampled variable blocks like
these di are randomly sampled it turns
out that this is related
to um an interesting topic in
convex geometry called zonotopes so
zonotopes are basically convex uh
polytopes um how they are defined is you
look at the convexal of um some XI UI
where UI is either zero or one okay
another way to define find this is you
take
the hyper cube right of sides 0 to one
and then multiply it by X transpose and
recall X transpose is a tall Matrix uh
sorry X is a tall Matrix X transpose is
a wide Matrix so it's a linear
projection of the unit uh hyper cube
right so some vertices of the hyper Cube
will basically disappear after there's
projection some Will Survive projection
here's an example if you have X1 and X2
as two rows of your Matrix the zonotope
generated by that is the con convex h of
0 X1 X2 and X1 plus X2 according to this
right and it is this set this diamond
shaped set with four vertices right so
if you generate an random Vector H and
maximize this linear function over the
zonotope you're looking for the support
functions and support points right
and you can see that this will happen at
vertices right linear functions are
maximized over uh vertices of a polytope
right if you pick this H actually you
will find this uh vertex if you pick H
in this direction you will find either
this one or that one right this is
actually what what's happening if you're
running this quantized embedding or this
random sampling process and you will
find a particular vertex if the vector H
happens to be in this cone right and
each vertex is an ass at cone right
these cones are actually describing how
important each vertex is you can
actually have a Vertex which is almost
not a Vertex right a very non-sharp uh
Edge right in that case the con will be
actually very narrow but that means
actually the variable is not important
it's almost a non-vertex
um and if you look at the maximizers of
this linear
function uh this is actually quite
simple and surprising if you maximize
this over UI for a given H you will see
that the result is sum of XI transpose h
plus because you can choose UI optimally
one xite transpose H greater than zero
just pick it one if it's on one side of
the plane right with normal H and zero
otherwise it will maximize this and this
is actually showing that the maximizer
is exactly this quantized
embedding right AR Max of this linear
function is one xh greater or equal zero
and this shows that the hyper
Arrangements have a one toone mapping to
the vertices of the zonotope each
chamber here right in this quantise
embedding is actually mapping to a
Vertex um and based on this actually we
can randomly sample the vertices of the
zonotope which is same as sampling
chambers of the zonotope and these kind
of ideas were actually explored in
computational Geometry
before so it turns out that the hardness
in the sampling problem is controlled by
the angles of the cones right each
vertex will have a have a cone right
which will show you when you will end up
in that vertex if you sample a random H
vector and we can Define this sort of
importance measure Theta I which is
proportional to the probability that you
will end up in that vertex if you sample
a normal Vector H right and this is
proportional to the solid angle how much
uh area is covered relative to the unit
uh sphere surface area and we look at
the minimum of these angles because
minimum one will dictate how hard the S
sampling is so here is the main result
so sample these di matrices by
generating random Gan hi okay and this
is same as apply locality sensitive
hashing to your data to get these dis
right each is telling you which bucket
the data fell in and the theorem says
that for any integer K we can obtain by
solving this reduced subsample convex
program we can obtain a one plus Epsilon
approximation where Epsilon is k + one
single singular value of x divided by
Lambda which is the amount of
regularization in the neural network and
if we do that we will have some number
of samples solving the condex program
will require n/ K to power K complex
times inverse of theta right and here
Theta is the minimum solid angle of the
zonotope so basically we reduce the
complexity from exponential in some
Dimension to exponential in K right
where K is the index of the effective
singular value basically
reducing exponential in D to exponential
in some effective Dimension right if you
have some data with uh decaying singular
values K will be the value uh of the
index right which makes a good
tradeoff
um and it turns out that actually if you
really sold this condex problem look at
how the neural network performs and
compare it with non-c condex
optimization right for instance
stochastic gradient descent here that's
what we do in a simple Benchmark here
it's c410 image classification data set
it turns out that as you sample more
this is the number of variables we
sample as you sample more the accuracy
increases this is test accuracy and it
actually
exceeds the accuracy you get with
non-convex
optimization so non-convex optimization
is actually very similar to what's
happening here it is randomly
initialized right but it is updated
through non-convex gradient descent here
we have some random initialization for
getting these patterns right which is
some hashing of the data and we Sol the
convex program in just one shot we use a
convex optimization solver and then you
get actually better accuracy which is
actually interesting so to me the most
surprising thing is the nonconvex Great
Des doesn't even optimize these
patterns if you randomly initialize
these patterns and then solve the
problem it works even better and this
was actually very surprising to me and
we came up with this uh optimization
toolbox for neural networks and we have
a uh performance profile this has done
over 400 data sets in the UC irwine
collection we declare a problem solved
if you get near 10 to minus 3 within the
global Optimum and we plot the
proportion of problem solved within this
400 data sets and we compare with Adam
and SGD and those we actually take 10
random initializations and 10 different
step sizes and we take the best of them
for our method we only sold the condex
program just once and the step size is
automatically selected by the optimizer
using line search it turns out that
actually you can get all these problems
solved to Global optimality or near
Global optimality in um
uh under 15 seconds whereas the other uh
optimizers do not even solve all
problems and it will take a very very
long time and from the optimization
theory side we know why this happens
because non-convex optimizers are are
solving a non-convex non- differentiable
problem due to the reu activation and
the convergence rate at best is to a
stationary point and it will be one over
root number of iterations in the convex
optimization world if you have a last so
like problem actually
nondifferentiability of that is not
really important because we have
proximal algorithms and the convergence
rate will be one over number of
iterations squared there's a question so
uh for this part are you uh fixing the
um like the model like the ne two layer
model right this is for two layer neural
networks the model A showed uh this plot
look the same if you sort of VAR that
model okay very good question the
question is does this change if we vary
the model for all two layer neural
networks which are fully connected or
convolutional it will be like this but
if it is deeper it will be different
which I'll probably come back to if it's
deeper then it's a different issue and I
I'll show you what happens a good
question okay and uh I promised you to
show that actually interpreting these
neural networks become easier with
randomized embeddings how does this
happen so let's say you have
some signal right it's just an array and
we are trying to predict the next value
using a neural network right so how this
works is you have some data frame from
here to here and you're trying trying to
predict the next value right and you
fill your data matrix by sliding this
time window right and then you run your
uh neural network you train it right
it's very very
common so if you look at this convex
program and the dis are randomly sampled
through this quantized anding or
locality sensitive hashen right what's
really happening is is you have these
middle signals these are the time
Windows my samples right you have a
hashing function which will hash it to a
different uh bucket right and over each
bucket you have this linear model and
this one will actually pick the most
concise
explanation of why right and of course
this makes a lot of sense because if you
go back to the signal over here I have a
very sharp change right I need a
different kind of model than the one
which is working over here where there
are no jumps right it breaks down your
signal into multiple blocks using
hashing and then over each block it is
learning a linear model of course this
works much better but I can interpret it
as just
hashing right so I claim that this is
more interpretable than just running
this blackbox neural network model
because at least we know what the model
is exactly
doing okay so finally I will show you a
framework to unify all of the things I I
said and I think this is uh providing a
new Avenue for randomized algorithms and
sketching so this is called Clifford
algebra so here is the interesting thing
I showed you that group PLO is what is
neural networks with reu activation
right what happens if your data is
onedimensional which is still a
meaningful problem you have
onedimensional points right and
labels um and the group lasso problem
reduces to lasso because group size is
one and we thought this is interesting
what happens then right and it turns out
that all of the constraints they
disappear in one dimension because
they're already satisfied
um and it turns out that you get this
lasso problem in the convex neural
network which looks like this it's just
this lasso that I showed you with some
Matrix K right no constraints we are
optimizing over Alpha and B this is a
bias term and the Matrix K is defined as
X IUS XJ Plus for each I
J okay and what is this doing what is
this doing is basically you have some
samples here X1 X2 X3 Etc right it is
actually fitting you a piece-wise linear
function right with break points at data
points but not every data point it is
actually a subset of the training set
because lasto we'll have a sparse
solution right and in this case the
zonotope will have vertices at these
data points only right and when you're
sampling you're basically sampling these
break
points okay make sense and this this was
interesting so it is just a pie by
linear model right in in one dimension
and the kings are some subset of the
data so then we realize that this
formula x i minus XJ Plus for the value
this looks like a kernel Matrix if
you're know about kernels in machine
learning right it's like a kernel uh
Matrix but it is different because
you're solving lasso this is not a
kernel method you realize that this is
actually the volume of the interval from
XI to XJ but it is the sign volume and
if you take reu it is the positive part
of the sign value basically it's like a
sign distance right so x i minus XJ plus
is going to be zero if XJ is larger than
XI which is on the other side of XI
right it's if it's on the opposite side
is actually measuring the distance in
this case it is just the volume right it
turns out that there's a very natural
generalization of test to high
dimensions for instance in two
Dimensions here is the convex program
right and kig J will be the volume of
the triangle between the origin x i and
XJ and this is actually a signed
area if the order of zero X ixj is
counterclockwise it's positive if it is
clockwise it is negative and plus we'll
make it zero if it is
clockwise and then there is this 2 over
XJ L2 norm and it turns out that this is
actually almost the neural network
problem because this is the natural
generalization and it turns out that in
any Dimension there is a formula this
will give you the neural network model
approximately in the following sense so
kig J is going to be the volume of the
parallelogram spent by these vectors
which are just the samples okay and
these indices they actually range over
every size the subset the J is actually
a multi- index and when you form the K
Matrix it is actually a very wide and by
and chose do and choose D
Matrix and there's some normalization
here involving the cross product of
these vectors and it turns out that if
you have this
inequality which is actually just
saying X is an L2 to L1 Subspace
embedding right one of the first
inequalities I showed you if you have
the Matrix satisfying a Subspace
embedding property from L2 to L1 this is
not L2 to L2 with parameter Epsilon then
this will give you an Epsilon optimal
neural network so it's actually very
very close if you have a nicely
distributed
Matrix and we know that this condition
will
hold if you have a r The
Matrix uh say IID gaussian and then the
number of samples exceeds D
times some factor of the Epsilon here I
think the best is Epsilon to minus four
so for random data it is actually the
case that neural networks are
approximately lasso models if we have
the Matrix uh as a Subspace
embedding so where does cord algebra go
into the picture so basically cord
algebra is a very nice mathematical tool
which generalizes linear algebra complex
numbers cotters cross products if you
actually know about this you don't need
complex numbers uh here in this uh field
you have multiv vectors which is a sum
of scalers vectors bi vectors Tri
vectors you have these uh higher grade
objects you form a veg product of two
vectors it is actually representing the
oriented area you can think of that as a
parallelogram in this case it is this uh
area
spent by A and B it is
signed uh you can have B vet product a
which will be minus a wedge product B
there's a way to define a product which
is do product plus wedge product and it
turns out that there will be a
multiplicative inverse this operation is
invertible and there's a notion of
dual which is giving you complimentary
subspaces uh if this was
three-dimensional the Dual will'll be
actually the cross product but it turns
out that this exist in any Dimension you
can Define these DS in arbitrary
Dimensions so it turns out that this
convex program you can write in terms of
the kford algebra so k j Matrix which is
previously a stated via volumes right it
turns out that it is actually the ratio
of two things at the top you have the
wedge product of your input sample with
a subset of training samples and then
you have normalization by L2 norm and
through some in geometric algebra this
reduces to the distance of XI the I data
point to the Fine Hall of other data
points D of them so it turns out that
there's this interesting formula this
kernal Matrix is basically measuring
distances to a fine Hall of subsets of
data and you have every
possible size d subset in the training
data which is representing something
like a concept and X I is projected to
it and you measure the uh distance and
it turns out that there's a formula for
the optimal neurons the neurons can only
be scalar multiples of the DU of this
wedge product which are perpendicular
it's the orthogonal complement of this
uh
object so basically by running this
quantized embedding we are getting
subsets right this is the uh locality
sensitive hashing right we are getting a
subsampling of these indices and then we
are basically subsampling this CIF
algebra we are solving the convex
program right this is actually how the
results work and the problem is actually
this is very high dimensional in the
case of uh typical fully connected
neural networks right there is also an
alternative scheme which is hinted by
this if you sketch the data by mapping
the data X to x times s apply a JLM Bing
on the right it is also preserved with
an Epsilon since all of these are in
terms of distances of of fine house to
the uh training data points so if you
sketch it on the right you will also get
preservation uh in terms of the optimal
value okay let me conclude here so
basically neural networks are high
dimensional convex models I think this
is one of the um important results I
talked about right and we had this
approximation uh mechanism which is
applying random sampling and you solve
the reduce Conex problem and it will
give you a neural network which is
approximately optimal um and there are
lots of open problems I think one open
problem is designing better sampling
strategies and better hashing better
sketching for the convex program which
will give you ways of making the neural
network training or maybe inference also
faster and I think exploring sketching
and sampling in the field of clip
algebra is a a new way I haven't seen
any results on that I think this is a
very promising Avenue thank you very
much for your
attention
thanks for a great talk any
questions yeah uh thanks for
the well child uh thanks for the great
talk um I'm wondering like as a high
level question do you think there are
any lessons that do you think there are
any lessons that people in you know the
applied deep learning community can take
away from your work because you know
it's very hard to change their mind to
like do something totally different but
do you think there's sort of like
tidbits that that they should take away
in what they're doing right now yeah
that that's a very good question so I
think there are a couple things one is
improving the optimizers right by
looking at the form of this conduct
program actually it's immediate that you
need to use a different Optimizer like a
proximal Optimizer and there's already
some work by other groups using these
proximal steps that's one and I think
the second thing is about interpreting
these models and simplifying them them
even looking at the ones as big as chat
GPT right and then interpreting them
through the lens of random hashing and
later actually simplifying pruning
compressing these neural networks so
that you get uh better
efficiency and maybe finally figuring
out why these are generalizing better
than other models that's another thing
you might be able to do with these
convex parameterizations and random
hashing
any other
questions mentioned they generalize
better have you looked at like the test
error as well or like it is like exactly
like your training error in the plot
very good question I can show you some
plots um for
instance this is one uh simple
experiment in c41 image classification
on the left you see training objective
value these trials are are for
stochastic gradient descent initialize
at different points so they go down
almost to this dash line and this dash
line is actually the objective value we
find by solving the convex program we
know that that's the optimum and they
almost reach there although there's a
gap this cross is the time it takes for
our convex solver to solve the problem
as you can see it's little bit after
this point but it gives you a better
objective value then the question is if
you optimize a little bit better maybe
10 to minus to order of that better do
you get better test accuracy
interestingly it is true if you look at
the test
accuracy this model the convex model by
doing this tiny bit better in training
accuracy it actually finds a much better
decision region and I think that's true
because even if you perturb your neurons
a little bit the decision region
actually becomes better and it can be
much much uh smoother right and you
actually get a bump an increase in the
test accuracy which is uh
interesting if I understand correctly
these are for two- layer neural Nets and
you mentioned that for deeper Nets
things change could you say more yes
okay that's an excellent question right
so all of the theory I presented you was
for two layer neural networks one
natural question is what happens if you
have one more layer and one more layer
and one more layer right so what happens
is so this is done at in the latest
nurbs paper if you have a three layer
neural network right turns out that
there is a convex program but there will
be even more variables in it because you
will have these di times DJ patterns and
right now what happens is you get the
hyperplane arrangements and inside each
arrangement you have another Arrangement
which is actually subdividing the
existing Arrangements because of that
you have more variables and this is true
as you are adding more layers you will
have more and more variables although
you get a convex program and there are
ways we are still exploring in how to
sample it better but let me also mention
there's one more way if you can train a
two- layer neural network you can
actually come up with a deep neural
network very easily by training layer by
layer right you train one two layer
neural network keep the layer you learn
and then keep it fixed learn my learn
one more layer and then learn one more
layer actually people came up with this
idea in deep learning to make sure
the GPU memory is enough for training
because the entire network might not fit
but a single layer can fit at a single
time right and if you do this actually
you get pretty good accuracy by the
addition of each layer you see the test
accuracy getting improved so right now
the problem is actually solving these D
problems in one shot that's why we are
having some sampling issues there are
lots of variables and then the other
alternative is to train it layerwise
which is uh which is working in practice
and to the layerwise training I imagine
your complexification techniques do
apply that's right right for this
layerwise each step is actually con
optimization right in fact you produce a
deep neural network entirely using
convex optimization each layer does
solve a group lasso
[Applause]
problem quick
question
thank you so uh as far as I know so we
gen when we Define random variables uh
over C for a so we don't have too many
concentration techniques that we can use
do you think that could be a challenging
for the research Direction you mentioned
oh okay very good question so I
think uh yeah you're you're raising a
valid point which is in cliford algebra
we do not have enough U mathematical
tools like concentration I think that's
true
but for some problems like tensor
sketching right there are mathematical
techniques and I think this cifer
algebra will be similar so what's
happening is basically in this case
there are these wet products and they're
generating High dimensional objects and
there's too many of them because there's
a combinatorial aspect right and then by
applying randomized hashing we reduce
the combinatorial aspect to it right
this is I think working okay but if you
want to sketch a veg product I don't
know entirely how that can be done but
maybe you reduce Dimensions like JL and
then take small dimensional wedge
products so what I meant was was that
but I I mean it's exciting because I
think this is not known in the field too
much and tools are going to be
interesting okay let's
[Applause]
[Music]
thank